not to get personal but how much do you
weigh
you may find out the next time you fly
trace gallagher is here with
this heavy news tucker we tend to forget
that weight gain can increase the risk
of diabetes heart disease and
plane crashes weight and balance is very
important to aviation safety and in 2019
the faa issued an advisory
to stress the importance of airlines
getting good estimates on how much
weight their planes are actually
carrying
and because the faa has noticed that
americans have put on more than a few
pounds
there's now a push to consider weighing
plus size
passengers we're told it won't be
anything as abrupt as tsa agents saying
take off your shoes pull out your
laptops and hop on the scale
but apparently scales and weight numbers
will be at airports at some point in
time
though the numbers will be hidden away
and you can always decline
to be weighed and they just choose a
different traveler tucker
amazing it's getting more fun to fly
chase gallagher thank you
you bet that's it for us tonight
reminder kirsty alley and tucker carlson
today tomorrow on fox nation
and now the great sean hannity from new
york
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else